I teach also because of course that's
part of the juice of the business of
Education and I research and write but I
am NOT faculty and I say that just
because I I don't want to misrepresent
myself and also because people who are
not faculty can still do faculty like
things keep that in mind and yes as Mary
Marshall mentioned i did my fieldwork my
dissertation fieldwork in brazil and i
talked with some of the students briefly
before we came up here about that and
i'm happy to answer questions about that
but tonight i'm going to talk about this
project and i'm going to talk about in
the following way this the images you
see are just going to roll and they're
going to just keep rolling it's about a
15 minute series I would love to
introduce you to the people I work with
at sanitation I would love to take you
on the street with me I would love to
take you to the offices and the garages
in the mechanical brooms that's not
going to happen tonight so the next best
thing is to let you have a visual
introduction to who they are and to
where they work and to who some of them
were in days gone by it's a it's a
collage if you will and there's also
there's there's language in here that
I'll talk about a little bit so I'm just
going to this is a this is going to roll
if I can that's not going to work and
we're going to lose a little bit on the
side and I think that's not a problem so
Allison asked me in class before we came
up what got me into this project and the
story it's a once-upon-a-time story I
was about 10 and I was with my father in
the adirondack mountains hiking and by
the way you some of your being very
polite to look at me while I speak
you're going to miss the picture so I
appreciate the gesture but you don't
need to we went hiking in the
Adirondacks and it was one of those
exquisite summer days where the part of
the forest my father had chosen for us
really looked as if no human hand had
ever touched it but for the trail and we
arrived at the lean-to
and it's on the edge of a lake with
mountains and perfect blue sky and this
was in the early 70s so Earth Day had
happened my parents were deeply engaged
with environmental concerns they were
very young when they had kids and so
their hippie their inner hippie came out
all through our childhood and they were
anti-war activists and environmental
concerns were particularly important so
we go in the woods my father and I we
get to the lean-to and behind the
lean-to in this absolutely pristine
place is a dump where campers have been
too lazy to pack out what they packed in
and even as a child I was about 10 or 11
I was incensed I was outraged and was
one of those moments and childhood where
an assumption gets exploded and it sort
of marks you and the memory sticks and
and what Mark me was this simple
question who did they think was going to
clean up after them I didn't know the
answer then I still don't know the
answer about that particular moment but
that question landed and started to
germinate even while I was doing my
fieldwork in Brazil in other words from
that point forward I kept looking around
thinking who cleans up where does that
trash go in Brazil you you the
neighborhood I lived in sometimes had
trash pickup and sometimes didn't so
there was the end of the plaza became a
kind of an impromptu dump for a while
the pig like that he fattened up on
those discards but when i finished my
graduate work here i realized that i
could actually be going to ask that
question more seriously in the context
of new york city and of course is the
answer to the question who cleans up
after us in New York meaning us there
there are actually many answers to that
but when i say us i'm defining I've says
residents householders who collects
municipal waste the Department of
Sanitation so then the question is
anthropologically what is that work and
who does it and what's it like and the
uniform how do you wear that uniform
these are not sanitation workers there
supervisors the next level up but I it
took me two years to get permission to
step into sanitation Chris for Ali
you're late I'm glad you're here oh
thank you Christopher's doing work on
dengue and trash in Brazil and he's
defending his proposal in February so
sorry oh it's so lovely it smells so
good and I've just put you on the spot
and you can sneak in front with you okay
got no problem I'm going to hold this
wow so one of the many challenges and
pleasures of working with any trash
related question is where you draw the
boundaries around it so when I started
asking what is it to be a sanitation
worker the question then expands to how
did the job get shaped the way it is and
then what's the organizational structure
underneath that and then what's the
historical moment that inspired the
structure and then what was the
political reality that influenced the
historical moment that so you keep
backing up and spreading out just like
garbage itself and and the boundary you
draw around it's partly arbitrary and
it's partly you the scholar make that
decision and it's partly permanently
always slightly beyond where ever you
draw the line there's more you want to
pull in so that as I say that's that's a
challenge and it's also a it's what I i
predict i will be working on this theme
and its tangential questions for the
rest of my life and I'm delighted to be
able to say that so I'm going to run
down just briefly it kind of a hit and
run because each of these could actually
be a book on to themselves and many of
them are the connections of the
sanitation worker on the street to these
much larger questions the who cleans up
after you issue is related to larger
environmental concerns in the following
way when we measure the cost of the way
we live now and by we I mean sort of
Western culture and we look at the
environmental ecological impact of our
lifestyle today and we have begun to
take a hard look at
costs the many many costs of the way we
live now one of the costs that not a lot
of people were actually considering was
the cost of the labor and I don't just
mean what's the budget for the labor I
mean what's the physical burden of
hefting and lifting and flinging and
driving and interacting with the
machinery we are in the most
technologically sophisticated age in the
history of humankind and this labor is
still done pretty much exactly the way
it's always been done pick it up you
carry it you put it into right now it's
a truck it used to be a cart and then
you have to transport it somewhere and
then you have to offload it that's all
exactly the way it has been for
centuries kind of since the invention of
the wheel I think so what is that cost
what is the cost to the human being so
that's one set of questions issues of
energy use it takes a lot of energy to
create all of the goods that then become
commodities that then we use and then
discard and then go somewhere they can
in themselves be used for energy and
incinerators that are called
waste-to-energy facilities rich and
thick controversies about that
technology which I won't go into tonight
getting it where it goes transportation
systems highways infrastructures
technologies of the truck itself new
york city uses something called up
ultra-low sulfur diesel it's far less
polluting however it works optimally
when the trucks on the road so when the
trucks idling while people are filling
it it's not so efficient as the it's not
ideal there may not be an ideal fuel
unless we could have the trucks run on
the garbage that they collect surely
someone's thought of that before I just
thought of that why don't we figure we
will figure that out we'll figure that
out that points to a whole other set of
questions we should not encourage any
kind of technology that lets you fuel
anything with waste because then we have
no incentive to stop making so much
waste so that's that's another on again
I'm not going to get into that tonight
specific I'm happy to talk about it when
we have questions but so the environment
the energy
energy use transportation systems and
infrastructure both of the trucks
technology of the trucks if you are a
truck manufacturer you measure the
success of the mechanism that pushes the
garbage out by what is the quality of
the turd it's the technical term
buttered that the truck makes when you
go to a dump and you empty the truck
there's a blade in the back of it that
pushes it and it when it's really
tightly compacted and conditions are
ideal it doesn't break up as it falls
out so it's like a turd right so how
well does that truck create a turd is
one of the measures of the success of
that particular truck and that points to
language that as you're seeing some of
the those are all slang from the job and
I've put together a glossary of slang in
fact you can have a can over here or be
part of an entire conversation that
someone not in sanitation would make no
sense of but to someone on the job is a
very efficient way of communicating all
kinds of engineering efficiencies and
technologies and science of
decomposition and of structuring a
landfill Fresh Kills landfill was once
the largest in the world it was one of
only two man-made objects visible from
space to the naked eye confirmed by NASA
by the way I thought that was just urban
myth but it's actually true I don't
think it's still true only because it's
really green now but you could only make
that if you were using some pretty high
falutin and very carefully put together
engineering specs and in fact Fresh
Kills it was open in 1948 it's now the
second largest park will be the second
largest park in the city system but
imagine what a landfill was like in 1948
it was a dump okay but the law is
changed and changed and changed during
its 53 year history and in the 1990s it
came into full compliance with EPA
regulations which meant that they double
lined underneath that was a feat that
was a spectacular feat hardly one we
celebrate but the waters around that now
are far cleaner than they ever could
have been otherwise so that's another
it's another sort of connection issues
of Public Health if we didn't pick up
the trash if the streets weren't clean
New York would not have the prominence
that we believe we have today in the
1860s when various progressive doctors
and activists and reformers were trying
to get the city to take issues of Street
cleanliness seriously they measured the
mortality rate and it was equal to that
of medieval London this was in 1866 even
then there were dozens of well does many
different preventable diseases they knew
how to prevent these diseases and people
were dying from them they didn't need to
be dying from them it wasn't only
because the streets were filthy but that
was one of the major factors and when I
say filthy I don't just mean litter I
mean Shin deep in mock years worth of a
mock imagine manure vegetable imagine
just all your street trash but add
manure and horse urine and cobblestones
and it was called corporation pudding as
a slang for the a slur on the city
government Tammany Hall then again
that's a whole other very interesting
side story sanitation issues point to
relationships of on many levels us with
each other if I drop litter in front of
you and it's your neighborhood or it's
just well what have I just told you
about what I think about that street
you're on that strudel I don't care
you're on the street I'm dropping my
litter maybe they're different people
understand and use litter differently in
different cultural contexts and it's a
little too easy to just say well
somebody's being careless and nasty but
it creates a relationship of the moment
then there's the city's relationship to
the larger region the region to larger
parts of the country New York City does
not have any place within its own
boundaries to dump its trash so all of
it is exported and in fact export is the
let is the term used for transporting
trash out of the cities the city limits
its I don't know this for sure but
talking to you now I think I'm going to
find out I'm going to bet it's the
single largest export we have as a city
i mentioned issues of consumption
it also points to time we wouldn't be
generating such quantities of
discardable stuff if we didn't have to
move as fast as we think we do this is I
call this our average necessary
quotidian velocity meaning I can't take
the time to clean my coffee cup remember
my ID like the handle broke I'm going to
get an off fix it I'll fix it but the
glue I can't hold the coffee cup ok I'm
going to just going to get paper but I'm
not going to take plastic bags anymore
i'm going to always have the cloth i
forgot the cloth part huh there's a
maintenance and a husbandry and a
shepherding on a form of attention that
those kinds of relationships with
objects require that we don't have time
for some of us do some of us are very
careful and caring about that but on the
whole most of us aren't and don't and
I'm not saying I'm not condemning any
but I'm just observing so issues of time
and then for me the central most
interesting question is that what I
started with the question of labor who
does this work what's it like to do this
work how are they perceived how do they
perceive themselves how do they receive
the people who are perceiving them how
do they perceive their bosses how do
they like the civilian workforce
sanitation employs just under 10,000
people approximately 70 200 are
uniformed and the rest are civilian in
everything from secretarial to lawyers
and consultants and not consultants
lawyers and policy analysts the
uniformed forces are arrayed like an
army so the sanitation worker on the
street is the equivalent of the private
then you have the supervisor
superintendent excuse me it's no water
oh wait behold thank you ok sanitation
workers supervisor superintendent and
then you have titles that change a
little bit now and then but it's
basically 1 star 2 star 3 star and
four-star Chiefs then you have the
commissioners and then you have the
Commissioner himself once you're at
Commissioner level
you are no longer uniform you are
civilian again but that structure is
quite intentional because when it was
put in place in the 1890s the fellow who
did that was a Civil War veteran and an
officer and he felt very strongly that
the only way to make this work work was
to break it down in very tightly
organized extremely the the lines of
responsibility and of hierarchy were
very clear and in fact he was right it
has worked ever since then apparently
this is a rumor but apparently deputy
mayor stephen Goldsmith has been known
to ask why are all these generals
walking around sanitation what does any
generals for and maybe he's referring to
when the officers wear their class a
uniforms because you see the stars of
their rank a raid on their shoulder like
in a military all right and I can tell
him why this is the way it is and I can
tell him why it was put there and I can
tell him why it works I invited him to
my talk next week he can't come but
maybe someday I'll have that chance hold
on just a second so who does the job the
public perception of who does the job is
that they are not too smart they took
that job because there's nothing else I
could do they it's an unskilled job says
the larger public and the people who go
to sanitation are of a lower calibre
than the people go to police or fire
which are the two other big uniformed
services in New York City and and what
I'm telling you is how they tell me the
public perceives them and some of the
examples of not too bright sanitation
workers on his route and a woman comes
out of our house on her way to work and
she's finished with her daily paper so
she offers it to the sanitation worker
and he says oh yes thank you and he
reaches for the paper and she's pauses
and says you can read right she's
serious she's serious the many cultural
examples a cartoon of a woman sitting
in a cafe with a man and he's wearing a
uniform that says something like Joe's
garbage service on the back and there's
flies buzzing around his head and
there's something stinky coming off of
his shirt and the caption says when
Myrna said she wanted to date a man in
uniform this was not what she had in
mind these are small examples but there
they jump out at the people who are
doing the work the most common story
that I've heard from many people or
example is that the teacher fourth grade
fifth grade who yells at the child
saying a boy always saying if you don't
study harder and if you don't get better
grades you're going to end up a garbage
man well what about the child who's the
child of a garbage man garbage man by
the way is like Negro or oriental it's
archaic it's not used it's not it's the
public still uses it but sanitation
worker is the phrase that sanitation
workers themselves use for themselves
and the phrase garbage man has been
they've been working to kind of unstick
that one from the public vocabulary
since at least the 1930s so help me with
that there are reasons that we think
sanitation workers are all of those
things they're stupid that it's
unskilled labor that let me just mention
on the issue of unskilled in the in the
strike of 1968 anybody who remember that
strike of 68 it was vivid right people
who lived here then they remember and if
you ever see the original version of the
movie the out of towners it was filmed
during that strike and there's piles
behind the jack lemmon and sandy dennis
or piles and piles of trash and they
even folded into the script at one point
it's a beautiful moment she's staring at
this mountain of trash in a pouring rain
two in the morning and she says who is
going to take it away and I'm watching
the movie say yes yes honey that's the
question when Rockefeller and Lindsey
locked horns over how to solve the
strike Lindsey said call in the National
Guard
Rockefeller said no I'm not going to do
that for lots of reasons one of them was
and this is not you you see this when
you read the press accounts of the day
but you don't when people give a quick
history of it they don't mention this
Rockefeller said the national guard
won't know how to do the job if it's
unskilled labor how could that be so I
like that little example among the many
reasons that we and i say we i don't
mean you you like your sanitation worker
i understand that you have nothing at
you you honor you celebrate you thank
you sanitation workers so the we is not
you individually people come to me with
that often like no no I like my cemetery
I believe you but as a sort of generic
public we see them in a couple of
different ways that's supposed to just
roll again the most obvious is through
issues of contagion right they are close
to and have their hands and noses and
bodies almost in piles of stuff that
stink piles of stuff that I know what it
is because it was in my fridge for way
too long or it was my kid's diaper that
I or it was the kitty litter it was the
whatever it is and now not only is it
stinky but it's all mashed together and
it's in a bag on the curb and I'm done
with it he has to pick it up and I used
the male pronoun quite consciously there
are women on the job and I'll talk about
that but fewer than five percent of the
workforce uniform workforces female so
i'm going to say he I mean no offense he
has to pick up deal with look at hang
out with all that stuff that I just
rejected so by association it's very
simple it's not even it's not like we
are bad because this is what we do it's
a human reaction after pelagic Lee you
see this in many many cultures that when
a person's labor or parts of their life
connect them in some way to objects we
have decided are tainted polluted they
buy by association also are polluted so
that's that's an easy one but then I
think we also have trouble with them
because we skip got them we
understand in many ways that the life
the way we live today the mountains of
trash that we generate it's not a great
system and it's not sustainable and it's
not environmentally healthy and there
are ways we can make different choices
and then some of those ways are a little
harder and I'm just going to throw out
my coffeecup when they pick it up it's
easier to kind of a heap blame on them
then have it reflected back on ourselves
for the systemic challenges of living
differently so I think another reason
that we have a hard time with them is
that they catch the blame and then
there's this is what I like a lot
because I think it has a lot of
resonance and implication when we throw
things out it tells us that the material
world around us is ephemeral and even
larger kinds of objects like chairs and
furniture and maybe even things that
have been in your family for a while
like your great-grandmother's pots that
she brought over from wherever and your
grandfather clock and the spectacles
your great grandfather wore something a
picture maybe even those treasures that
we've marked across generations that
have a depth of meaning and Association
even those they're not permanent either
and if you back it up what is permanent
they make that point every time they
show up on your block the ephemera the
impermanence the fleeting nature of
materiality is something that they stand
for and that's another reason it's hard
to kind of give them attention positive
attention and then finally they
represent a kind of an interruption or
an eruption the trash is on the street
and it's not supposed to be there very
long they're supposed to come and take
it away and then the street is clean
well it's as temporarily clean as it is
temporarily holding the trash but the
trash off the street that's normal so
when they come down especially if they
have to block the cars behind them it's
a it's a break the rhythm is broken the
visual harmony that you expect that's
broken because of them it's not because
of them they're saving us from ourselves
but that's not how you read it when
you're I mean when I turn down the block
and the truck is in front of me I'm no
happier about that than you are I check
to know if I know them and if I'm stuck
there for a while I might get out and
say hello but if I'm in a hurry I don't
want to be behind that truck so those
are reasons that sanitation workers are
understood to be like you wouldn't want
your child to be a sanitation worker
maybe when you step into the job though
one of the many things i learned there
was an incorrect assumption on my part I
thought that they all wore this stigma
like a heaviness like a like it the job
itself was a burden like these guys have
miserable lives out in the world because
of their jobs oh not at all the stigma
is real enough for some that they don't
tell their neighbors what they do for a
living it's real enough for some that
the famous story is a superintendent who
was in a Manhattan garage who left his
house every morning in some suburb in a
suit with a briefcase and when he got to
work he changed into his uniform
sanitation uniform and before he went
home he put back on the suit but then
there are the people who it's it's a
great job and they make a good living
and the pension it's called a short
pension 20 years you retired half pay
not bad if you want to we can get into
the thicker political debates right now
about pensions I have some thoughts
about that they don't they understand
that the job is stigmatized but they
don't wear a stigma that's not their
problem that the public doesn't get it
or the public miss reads it they have a
job that in many cases they love and
they're happy to tell whoever wants to
hear about it and they've got rich
stories their own language a depth of
camaraderie that I envy partly because
they are in the trenches in the war on
crime right that's it an old sanitation
punt Oh next time you see a sanitation
worker
well there's a few things I want you to
do tell him thank you you will amaze
them just that just say thank you I was
crossing 110 street a couple of mornings
ago and it was collection day for here
and there was a truck stopped at the
light and I scurried across and I
stopped in front of the truck and I want
like this and the guys went like this
and I said and they both went it was a
lovely lovely moment it was a lovely
moment because they don't get thanked
they don't get thanked I'm not saying
they're heroes some of them are some of
them art most of them are just doing
their job a lot of them take pride in
doing that job well so that's one thing
I want you to the other thing I want you
to do oh shoot what was I talking about
before the Thank You thing I'm sorry I
lost that thread oh yeah yeah okay thank
you the solute here I will teach you the
Sandman salute that's it okay here's
what they know about the job the way the
eight hours of their shift is carved up
is an extraordinary study of
understandings and use and control over
time they have to be ready to walk out
the door in uniform with their orders in
hand at 6am orders in hand means they
have their route they understand if
there's anything unusual going on that
day on their route that means i have to
get there ahead of time obviously
wearing your uniform to work very low
class you have your uniform in your
locker if you're wearing your uniform to
work it means you're so disorganized in
your life you don't have time to get
there enough to put on your put your
street clothes on the hook and change in
your uniform and do you wear that home
at the end of the day that's disgusting
it isn't always if you it the day well
you can imagine on a very hot sweaty day
you're gonna anybody working outside in
a hot sweaty day might be a little right
but there's it you don't wear the
uniform home you don't wear it to work
you change when you get there
and then 622 is the standard shift day
line shift 15-minute break at eight
o'clock half hour lunch at ten o'clock
ten-minute break at and forget when
afternoon but before one depending on
where you dump that truck you have to be
done with your route by a very specific
time how long does it take you to get
from your garage to the start of the
route they know that in miles and in
minutes how long does it take you to
complete each line of that route they
meaning the department management know
that in miles and in minutes and in
weight you will get on Thursday December
second in Manhattan 7 section 5 which is
here no that's it it's from 110 to 90th
that's section 5 of Manhattan 10 you are
in section you're in manhattan 9 they
know exactly you're going to get
approximately this time of year 13 tons
and change and if you don't you're going
to have to talk about why and your
supervisor will be following you to make
sure you didn't miss a collection or
you're not hiding out or you're not
walking backwards which is one of the
slings I think might be up there on the
street you will know especially if
you're in one garage for a long time you
will know those streets probably better
than anybody in the city and you won't
just know the hydrants that are broken
and the tree that seems to be tipping
over into the little guard on the set
you will know a whole lot of detail
about the people whose homes you collect
a detail that you may not want to you
might not like knowing that these
details about you are things they no
prescription medicines sexual
proclivities drinking habits reading
habits children how many what sex a
divorce on a fair very intimate
knowledge about you spills out of those
bags when those bags break we put them
in the back we put the garbage in the
bags dark bag tie it up put it out
evidence is gone no it's not and they
see it now do they care I I realized
that when I talk about this some people
like yes
this is this is risky because they're
really interested in me and I should
make sure that I shred those documents
better well that's a separate thing you
should tread it up but not that they're
going to go through it because they
don't they don't have the time and they
don't really care that much about you as
individuals they're not that interested
they will notice patterns over time but
they're not wondering Oh on 108 Street
remember that woman and she's quit
drinking and then I saw the Jackie I
wonder what's up with her today they're
not that involved they will however
there's a story of a man who was he
picked up one of the big big big
apartment buildings down by behind
Lincoln Center that was his route for
many years and on a lower floor was a
family a couple that moved in they had a
baby a little girl she grew up she went
to school she went to went to college
that sanitation worker on that child
knew each other pretty well and when she
left for college she gave him a gift in
her card and they had a very cheerful
partying and when he retired he went to
make sure that the family knew he was
retirement is where it was a lovely
relationship but that's unusual enough
that it's a story out of that garage so
but if you think your trash is private
it's not other things that they know and
parts of the job there are three
elements to doing the job there's the
rules there's the bureaucracy and then
there's the job itself if you follow the
rules you can't do the job that's I
thought this was some great revelation
about sanitation and I would make this
fantastic contribution to labor history
that's not so unusual inside any large
heavy handed organization like
bureaucracy is I'm sorry like sanitation
is it's a particularly hot button issue
right now because of the demotions of
the supervisors that you may have read
about in the press recently they've
demoted a hundred supervisors back to
sanitation worker when they return to
those ranks they will have lost all
their seniority so even if they've been
on the job for five or six years they're
going to be on the bottom of the wrong
and the whole job is built around
seniority and they're mad they're really
really mad understandably so one of
their push backs right now
is we are going to follow the rules to
the letter and that means the job is not
going to get done the streets are not
going to get clean the baskets are not
going to get emptied the broom routes
are not going to be finished brooms
mechanics mechanical understanding of
machinery that's another skill how do
you fix if the truck is making a funny
noise when you have the garbage scooped
up into the back what does that mean
what can be many different things
depending on the noise how do you know
well that takes time it takes experience
it takes being taught it takes somebody
pulling a gag on you where they was with
a crew one day and before they left
unbeknownst to them one of their
colleagues had set the blade in such a
way that it wouldn't move meaning here's
the truck the cab of the truck is here
right so when you start the day there's
a there's a wall of it's like a big
metal wall here and as you fill the
truck this moves back and then there's a
blade a movable blade here that squashes
it and squashes and squash is it so it
compacts that's how a truck built for 12
tons can hold 15 tons but there's a way
that you've mess around with the
mechanics so that the blade won't move
well you can't you can't do your work if
the labor move because you can't put the
garbage in the truck so this crew went
all the way back to the garage and all
their colleagues were laughing because
they said didn't you flip the movements
which I forget what it was called which
any beginner knows so claimed the senior
guy and this poor fellow was very
embarrassed because of course she would
he should have known that not that
anyone would have taught him that during
training it's what you pick up while
you're while you're working so there's a
there's a depth of knowledge one of the
insults you can lob at someone and it's
not usually you don't usually say it to
someone's face but you'll say it about
someone especially if they've been
promoted recently it's a sort of a
two-part they mean the same thing he's
got no time meaning he hasn't been on
the job very long now I've heard that
set of people 17 years on the job so no
God no time is relative that the 17-year
guy was junior in a sanitation garage
where they've all got 22 23 27 years so
yeah 17 years he was junior guy he was
getting the scut assignments he's got no
time or
he's a know-nothing he doesn't know
anything he doesn't know the job that's
the other insult he doesn't know the job
that you hear that when you have a
sanitation worker who's been on brooms
brooms is a separate assignment then be
promoted as an up to being an officer
doesn't know the job is a broom guy or
the brumis who feel that they're
slightly more intelligent than their
truck driving colleagues when a truck I
gets promoted the broom ii will say he
doesn't know the job he came up from the
trucks just just by way of a little
background as as part of my research
enter to understand this job as well as
possible i took it for a while i was i
went through the process of i took the
tests i went through all the medical
clearances and all the x-rays and i had
a bad moment in the clinic when i had to
stand and demonstrate flexibility i said
i right touch your toes i haven't been
able to do that in years and i thought
well this is he on the line for me and i
was very of like I'm so so I can't well
I can't do the job I can't touch my toes
and luckily she said that that was not
in fact a make-or-break qualification
but I I was assigned two brooms and I
was training to to operate the
mechanical brooms you don't drive rooms
you operate the brooms and I will tell
you they are marvelously complex
sensitive machines the brooms there's a
different one on each side the gutter
brooms you can tilt them at different
angles depending on how what the
conditions are you also can have one up
and one down you have to pull them both
up if you're going over certain kinds of
ground the pickup room in the middle is
the big one that picks up the garbage
and puts it on where to called the
flights which is like an angled conveyor
belt that goes into the hopper of the
broom it holds about a ton you have to
clean that every day and you have to
clean it really well and you clean it
with a fire hose so you have a fire hose
and you have the wrench that unlocks the
hydrants and a key it's called and when
I was in training actually I wasn't a
training anymores on the job and we were
in the Bronx and I was I had a company
Abreu me for a few days but now he's in
my own room so we met at the
point and that he cleaned first and then
he pulled the head and then I pulled out
my hose and hooked it up to the hydrant
and while you do this the hopper of the
room is tipped open so you can get at
the innards and if you have never held a
firehose full of water fire hose of like
squirting water it's a it's a force it's
you need some strength and it will get
away from you if you're not careful it's
not a garden hose it's a whole other
thing and I didn't know that and so I
pick it up and I'm like fighting with
the hose and I aim it from my broom for
the flights and I didn't see the woman
who was walking around us and it went
all the way over the broom and it hit
her square and it was this time of year
and it was this kind of day and she was
I have to say extremely gracious uh she
she could have done many many many
things that she didn't do and I hadn't I
tried to give her my jacket i had enough
that mean that the only other cloth
besides what i was wearing was rags we
used to clean grease off of some of the
fittings as you can't all here wrap
yourself in this green we left really
quickly after that because if she had
realized that she should have gotten the
broom numbers are the uniform now as of
2002 you have to have your name on the
outer layer of your uniform which is the
commissioner said to help instill pride
in the job but of course the
rank-and-file knows it's really about
surveillance although it looks good I
got to say the white letters look if you
can make up a name maybe then it would
be kind of fun but we were we were we
were out of there very fast that day so
there are their levels of skill and it's
also things like how do you manage the
relationships of a garage how do you
understand the board there's been a
picture through here of how the jobs are
assigned and how the how you know what
you're doing the next day and it's
talmadeus it's Byzantine
it's I've had it explained to me many
many times and I still like I would
someone would explain this to me and i
would say okay let me now explain it
back to you and i never got it right i
never got it right setting the board is
a is a very who has the power to set the
board has a lot of power in the garage
so it's a it's a job trust a few very
trusted people are given that privilege
in some garages it has to be a union
person 831 local or in other garages it
can be a civilian person but that's kind
of negotiated in each place as it fits
each place which points to another
lovely cultural reality of it each each
garage has its own kind of subculture so
what what goes what works in Manhattan
seven which serves the upper west side
of manhattan might not fly at all in BK
17 or bronc 6 and when you go to those
garages especially if you transfer your
smart to just kind of watch for a little
while and figure out what the house
rules are it's not that the house rules
are sort of legislated or in place in
ways that you can get in official
trouble although some of them are but
it's more just the habits the mill the
mill the assumptions the the ways in
which people in that garage organized
their relationships around the labor so
there's like fifty nine books waiting to
be written just one each I thought of
organizing my work to stir on one garage
specifically but it grew like garbage
does so there's one more there's one
more point I want to make about issues
of stigma and perception and knowledge
and then I'm going to talk a little bit
about oral history and then open it up
for discussion um when you put on the
uniform of a sanitation worker you are
invisible eyes and I know this from
hearing many stories about it but I also
know it from my own experience when I
was on the job even before I was on the
job when I accompanied crews and would
would join them for for for instance
cleaning up after the
west indian day parade in Brooklyn or
Times Square New Year's Eve or any of
the sort of special event cleanups
before I was on the job I had a uniform
and I would get on the subway or bus or
walk down the street and it was
remarkable how thoroughly unseen I was I
had never experienced it before like
that to the point where when I was
sweeping with a hand room down Ocean
Parkway in Brooklyn after the west
indian day parade the hand room has
bristles made of metal and if it's a
warm day and the people who are still up
against the barricades are wearing
sandals you want them to move because
you're going to scrape their feet so
what's the polite thing do you say
excuse me but they don't hear you they
don't see you you're right here but
you're not there at all and I watched my
fellow workers they weren't saying
excuse me because they already knew that
they weren't even there to the people at
the parade so they're just sweeping and
if they caught someone's feet the person
would jump back and maybe curse them out
they're going to do the job so it was
that's where the stigma issue can
sometimes come back that can sometimes
be real and bitter for people who
generally don't don't aren't troubled by
it at all and it actually points to the
work of Merrill new Calise Merrill Adam
and you Calise is the artist in
residence for sanitation she has been
since 1977 and has done a series of
remarkable works performance works and
landscape works around issues of
sanitation garbage labor and she
invented something at in the late
seventies that she called maintenance
art how do we understand the the systems
and structures on which we rely for
basic maintenance of anything in ways
that can become much more creative and
vibrant in our understanding of them so
maintenance art is her one of her many
contributions to this this way of
thinking so oral history in the spring
i'm teaching a class at NYU
called oral history what did I name this
class labors of waste and the value of
knowledge we are going to work with
sanitation people from all ranks from
all histories from all backgrounds
civilian uniform retired still employed
brand new hires 50-year veterans ideally
someday I would like to have a hundred
it's a good round number it's going to
take a while to get there but the class
will be the first formal effort to make
this happen we did a class a couple of
years ago we meaning myself and my
colleague Haiti guy smart who's in
anthropology and Museum Studies on how
do you start a museum from scratch and
we use sanitation is the case study and
we we we created the seed from which a
sanitation museum will grow and part of
that will be the oral history archive
and we did interviews then but they
weren't transcribed they weren't they
were just interviews recorded interviews
which I now understand is a whole
different thing from oral history
although it can serve similar purposes
but so the spring each student will do
two interviews transcribed to what I
call the gold standard the Columbia
University standard and among the many
questions that i'm looking forward to
wrestling with with my students are
issues of things like where the oral
tradition in the oral history overlap
where how do we use social media if at
all I've found Facebook to be a
remarkably rich source of insight about
sanitation life when my facebook
sanitation friends start talking about
the specifics of their job like a broom
operator who talks about how much she
hates leaves oh yeah leave suck they
stick you got to go over him again and
again they gum up the works and so today
she did leaves and it was a short dump I
don't know what a short dump is I've
been hanging around the Sanitation for a
long time and I don't know what a short
dump is that's pretty interesting so
that will help us inform some of the
questions that we use to craft our
interviews as well as reaching out to
people who would be willing to be part
of this endeavor what do we learn but
what am i sending my students out to
discover what's what are the framing
questions that we're going to use to
organize what we go after I don't know
yet and and I'll elaborate that or
articulate that a little more clearly
before the semester opens but it's also
something that I want us to kind of
throw on the table and toss around a
little bit at the start of the semester
when we are interviewing all the usual
dynamics come into high relief what is
the difference in age sex color class
education of the interviewer and the
interviewee as you know those are all
very significant factors how do we what
are we going to how are those going to
play out how are those going to shape
the interviews themselves are we going
to get life stories or oral histories or
both are we going to make a distinction
between those how might these be used
later at this moment in the city's
history and when I say later I mean like
two weeks after their deposited or 20
years from now at this moment in the
city's history sanitation is in the
crosshairs for some restructuring
initiatives from the mayor's office will
people be less less willing to talk
openly because of this moment or will
they be more eager to tell stories
because of this moment how will this
moment in Flex color shape the kinds of
stories we hear I don't know also it
depends keep the supervisors right now
who are being demoted and it's rippling
the whole job is being restructured the
whole job at that level is being
restructured some of their stories if
they're willing to tell them are going
to be deeply angry ferociously
venomously expletive ly furious and some
of them are going to want to tell those
stories because they're so angry okay
well what does that do what kind of
archived is that well how does that
shape the larger project of the archive
I don't have the answers to those
questions and it's some of the stuff I
hope we can discuss tonight the archive
the museum those are projects I'm sorry
the public the oral history project and
museum our projects moving forward
slowly but they're moving forward the
archive project is another one where
we're gathering and putting into one
safe place and eventually organizing
cataloging making available archives
like I don't know if any of you are
aware of what the Department of
Environmental Protection did across the
last five to six years they've organized
a remarkable collection from boxes of
debris basically and it's been a kind of
a one or two or three people show if any
of you were doing any research relevant
to water in New York City the DEP
archives are a gold mine and the the
archivists are eager to make them
available so reach out to them if that's
useful and then there's the Wall of
Honor project you are three times more
likely to be killed or injured in the
line of duty as a sanitation worker then
you are as a police officer or
firefighter the reasons for this are
there's a few reasons you're getting in
and out of a truck in track in traffic
the most recent fatality was January of
this year when a man named Frank just
itch was on the street side of his truck
cycling the hopper meaning he's made
that scooping blade thing activated
which is very loud Anna tractor-trailer
turned into early morning sun glare with
a very dirty windshield so he wasn't a
hundred percent aware of what was around
him and the body of the truck caught
Frank and that was it two young children
beautiful young wife that the the
ceremony to rename the garage after him
was about two weeks ago and I've been to
many many such the funerals and the
ceremonies this one was somehow even
more somber than usual so there's
getting an hour traffic the mechanics of
the truck itself the hopper I don't have
any pictures in here but oh I have a
model I have a toy model I should bring
it for these talks you meant ok so this
is the truck the hopper opens in the
back so the garbage pushes out this is
held up by hydraulics the hydraulics
sometimes malfunction and then this
drops if you're anywhere within its
range when it drops you will probably be
killed
and if you're not killed you'll be
seriously disabled a man was caught by
the hopper two weeks ago he only
suffered three broken ribs he was
thinking it was time to retire he got
called by the hopper he's retiring he
took it as a sign he's supposed to get
out so the mechanical mechanical its
large heavy equipment and it will cause
harm sometimes and then there are
accidents driving I can tell you many
examples but statistically the bureau of
labor statistics ranks it among the 10
most dangerous jobs in the country it
changes ranks sometimes it's above
mining sometimes it's below mining deep
sea fishing tends to stay near the top
police and fire aren't even on that list
of top 10 it's not to say their jobs
aren't dangerous but when a sanitation
worker takes this job because he says
I'm safer he's wrong he's just wrong so
I could go on and on and on and on and
on and on and I did ask the people i
talked with in the class before i had to
cut me off because i would go on on a
month but i think it's a good place to
break and i see some people beginning to
maybe